good morning
welcome to sunday morning science john
perry here i am very excited about
today's
presentation i've got j forsythe on with
me
he is a assistant professor at the
college of charleston
and i met him when he was doing his
post-doc with
georgia tech at the center for chemical
evolution
so i've been working with the center for
chemical evolution since i think it was
2013 that i first started going maybe
it's 2014
that i first started going to their
meetings and doing animations for them
so if you go to the stated clearly
channel you'll see
a whole series of animations about the
origin of life that i've done with them
and this center there's uh it's
it was located at georgia tech but they
have satellite groups all over the
the country different research labs and
there they've just been for the past
like decade been looking into the origin
of life
and doing all sorts of different
experiments exploring different aspects
of the origin of life and jay
has focused a lot on peptides so
you know the the origin of of different
proteins
and we're going to talk a little bit
about his technical work
but also just his experience in this
jay is he comes from a christian
background he is a christian
and he has spent a lot of time doing
outreach
with christian groups you know origin of
life science i've i've noticed over the
years i have
uh a healthy chunk of my audience is
christian
and some of them are
they feel that their religious faith is
at odds with
things like evolution and origin of life
research
and so we're going to be talking to jay
about kind of how he's
navigated that in his own thinking
and jay
welcome to sunday morning science i'm
really glad to have you here
thanks john it's great to be here yeah
i'm excited i can participate
and hopefully i can bring some helpful
perspectives
yeah yeah and as always
audience if you have questions do do at
space stated casually and i'll be able
to answer those
well we'll probably pause several times
throughout the conversation
and answer those and you know if you're
having trouble hearing or anything like
that just
let me know there in the comments my dog
hazel says hi
also great great
so jay just
just kind of to get started you know
i've
i've worked for a bunch of different uh
research centers now i've worked with a
lot of different scientists
and it's kind of funny because it's
really hard to become a professor it's
really hard to get into research
but i've actually met quite a few
researchers
who sort of just fell into it like they
were good at
math when they were in middle school and
then they liked chemistry in high school
and just one thing led to another and
bam they just kind of
fell into this career and they're
they're not super excited about it
but at the center for chemical evolution
it seems pretty much everybody's excited
i mean i i haven't met anyone there that
i'm like
oh this person is isn't really that into
what they're doing it seems like
everybody's
really into this this project but you
especially
you spent a lot of time with me helping
me
get oriented in the field when i first
started working with the center
and you're doing this outreach stuff
with christian groups and that
that's through the um what what
organization is that through
it's through uh aaas which is the
american association for the advancement
of science
right so they're they're probably best
known for being the publisher of the
journal
science yeah right but they they're
based in dc
and they do all kinds of policy work
they do all kinds of things yeah
and then you're you're um what's the
name of that program
the the outreach uh well specifically
um one of the ones that i help out with
is called the science for seminary so
it's um i'm i'm
i don't run the program by any means i'm
just one of their helpful like
advisors and yeah yeah basically what
they do
is they help train
um seminary professors how to
incorporate science into their seminary
courses
um so that you know religious persons in
the in the u.s
can kind of get more solid science
content and kind of a better
understanding of science and also
seeing how science can apply to you know
things like
um like psychology
right you know like for example like
when when you have a religious community
a lot of times the persons in that
community will go to their religious
leader for
personal advice or even like you know
mental health
issues and things like that right and so
um
it's really important that they get good
sound science so so i like i usually
talk about chemistry
topics or origins of life topics but
there are all kinds of scientists that
participate and help out with that
program um it's a really cool program
yeah that sounds great uh yeah i've i've
been interested in uh
and and trying to uh do something with
them
as well but it's i never have but
um so
it's it's it's very clear that you go
above and beyond in your
you know outreach and stuff you're very
excited about this topic
and i'm my first question to kind of
start off the day is
how what got you interested in this how
long have you been interested
in chemistry and specifically in the
origin of life
yeah so um going back to what you said
earlier i would i would consider myself
one of those people that kind of fell
into it
but it was kind of one of those happy
accidents right where
um so i i guess i'll just talk about
kind of how i grew up so i grew up
going to a very religious
small private school you know like it
was private but not like
well-funded you know yeah um and the
science
education i got there was not the best
um
to say so basically i never i was never
taught the theory of evolution
in class until i was a college student
right
hold on i think our stream has stopped
somehow okay god um
let me ask a question here
god what's going on
youtube has been crazy with me today
um
okay someone says it's working now
but
okay
all right let's continue sorry sorry
about that interruption there no it's
okay
um so yeah so i i grew up
uh k through 12 at a very small
religious school
um certain aspects of my education were
really good
you know like i felt like my liberal
arts education was excellent i felt like
i was
a pretty good writer for being like
being a high school student
um my math was very good and so like you
know like i like we had
calculus and stuff like that in high
school but
my science was not you know my my
chemistry labs were like putting peeps
in a microwave
and things like i'm serious like really
you know like yeah like i never like
when i was a college freshman and we did
like real chemistry labs like that's the
first time i had really ever done
anything like that before wow
wow wow okay i definitely felt
behind the curve when i started in
college
compared to a lot of my friends and who
were all i was a chemistry major
that were other chemistry majors but you
know i like i
i felt like we all kind of evened out
quickly you know
once once you kind of get over some of
those introductory courses
everybody's kind of jumping in from
scratch you know and so
um but i was always i guess growing up i
was always a curious
person right you know i was always
asking questions i was always thinking
about
the implications of what i was taught
you know and
um i started to i guess question some
things that i was taught
even while i was still in that school
right so
um and there were there were people that
helped me do that you know
one one person i always think of was my
ninth grade earth science teacher
his name was mr whitware right and um
you know i haven't spoken with him in 20
years
yeah i'm sure he's not listening to this
but um we could send him a link
um so he he basically taught
that you know he taught us plate
tectonic theory
and argued you know like based on based
on the earth
as it is you know it seems very likely
that the earth is old
and this the idea of like a young earth
creationism
is not supported by the evidence right
yeah and
um even that at my school was
controversial right so
he left he left a couple i think a year
or two after i had him
and you know i don't know what happened
but i wouldn't be surprised if
he was pushed out based on like some of
the parents not liking what he
taught right yeah he did not teach he
did not teach evolution right he was
just
teaching old earth like older theory
right like he wasn't necessarily
teaching anything on creationism it was
just saying
i don't like i don't think the earth is
six thousand something years old
so so evolution was totally banned in
that school
yeah yeah you know i like honestly i
think they just avoided it
you know it it was one of those schools
where the
you know when those small private
schools there's there's like a number of
families
you know like the families basically run
the school in a sense
and i think that they wanted to kind of
avoid it because they were worried if
people disagreed about it you know they
would
yeah that would cause all this drama
right and so
i think they just avoided it like i i do
remember that we
read inherit the wind right the play on
the
scopes trial right yeah i don't really i
remember reading that in middle school
but i don't really remember if they
made an argument of like who was the
good guy and bad guy i feel like it
might
i feel like most most people sided with
the william jennings bryan side i think
right yeah um you know like he like hit
like like standing firm in his faith
like no matter what right um
but that's really all i remember you
know like
um we talked about the theology related
to
like the creation story coming i came
from a kind of more like evangelical
um like persuasion right so kind of like
the genesis like
the first two chapters of genesis yeah
right and like kind of theological
implications of those um i i do remember
being told that
that word day could be translated
multiple ways
but that was really it right that was as
far as they ever went and
when i was in high school you know i
started to be i was starting to
be interested in science but i was a
little frustrated just because i felt
like
my science teaching wasn't great um
and i thought i was going to be a doctor
and so i was like i'm going to go be a
chemistry major and then go to med
school
yeah so i went to college and i started
taking like chemistry and biology
and i just loved i fell in love with
science i
like i knew that that was what i wanted
to do and
do more like pure science as opposed to
medicine right yeah yeah
um a lot of my friends that were when
they went off to med school too
um and my freshman biology class was
where i did learn
the theory of evolution for the first
time and i just
i thought it was fascinating i thought
it was amazing you know it's one of
those
it's such a it's such a grand idea yet
it's so
like simple and clean too you know like
it has this like
i don't know some of my my favorite
scientific scientific ideas are
they're they're huge and they change how
you see everything but you can explain
it in a sentence or two
right right you know like there's
there's this profoundness yet a
simplicity to it
and um i knew right away i was like oh
yeah like like
like this is awesome like like this like
like i
like i really think this happened right
um
and it i wouldn't really say it
it changed my faith per se you know like
i guess
my faith was already evolving in a sense
even before that you know i was becoming
more open-minded
um in terms of uh
kind of like seeing things from other
people's perspectives right
and um you know the the kind of the more
evangelical tradition that i grew up in
was you know it was it was very
like that the theology behind it was
very personal like like you know
this is like you and god and it's not
about anybody else
you know in a sense and and
like my faith became more of the
opposite like i felt like
i wanted to i wanted to have like more
of a communal
idea right and so i guess my my my faith
was still there but it was changing
and so by the time that i started
learning evolution
it didn't really throw me into shock
right and and i know it does you know i
i had conversations with people
all the way back in college at the same
time we were taking that class that it
did
right yeah and so i know that that's i
know that that happens a lot but i guess
i was my my
spirituality was starting to morph maybe
even before
like that hit me and so i think i was
kind of maybe a little more ready for
that
that lesson um yeah that's really
interesting because because the uh
yeah a lot of people they just evolution
is just this it's either evolution or
it's a god
and i i i find it really interesting
that you were
you know it because because you're in
tennessee right
uh well so i'm in south carolina no no
no but you were raised in tennessee
right
i was born in tennessee actually was
raised outside in the suburbs of
philadelphia but we
i moved back south so i was in i went to
college in south carolina and then grad
school in tennessee so yeah i've spent
about half my life in the north and half
of the south yeah
well i lived in tennessee and that's
actually when i started the stated
clearly project
and it was because so many of my friends
were
really really anti-evolution and i i was
trying to
share stuff with them about it but
all the textbooks were too technical and
then if i were to share them like a
video by richard dawkins or something
it'd be peppered with insults
towards christianity so i'm like oh yeah
there's not there's nothing really good
here
that's so i started the stated clearly
project in it i mean that was
that was the genesis of it so yeah a lot
of people have had that uh
really really strong it's
either either god or it's evolution and
i think that's a
kind of a horrible dichotomy there
so yeah yeah that's really interesting
that it wasn't even an issue for you
yeah i mean i guess i mean it was
definitely something i've spent a lot of
time thinking about but
it was never this like internal struggle
i would say
um i was also fortunate to find you know
some
voices like you know like like through
like writing or like
you know different places that were kind
of
they were either saying that you know
like religion and science can coexist
right you know that they answer and they
ask and answer different questions
you know that's kind of more like the
steven j gould idea
right yeah um or you know like like
there there are
there are some very prominent christians
and religious persons who
are highly respected scientists who
argue for evolution you know like
like i probably the best known one is
the creator of biologos
francis collins right he's the head of
nih right yeah he did
he he he headed the uh human genome
genome project for the
yeah the federal side yeah yeah
yeah i've written for biologos i don't
know if yeah i don't know if i
said that to you but yeah you know and i
think that like his perspective
and stephen j gold's perspective all you
know they're kind of in between
both of them are kind of in between that
either like it's only god
or it's only evolution right um
and they you know they their
perspectives disagree with each other on
some places and some places they agree
you know like i guess
i almost find myself kind of in between
those two in some way in some ways
you know yeah um like i i think that
steven j gould would argue
he he he had his turn he turned at noma
it's like non-overlapping
magisteria right it's basically like you
know theology
or religion or spirituality and science
you know they're just different spheres
of questions and
ways of knowing right yeah and they
don't they don't overlap right
and and that means that they can coexist
um and then i think that francis collins
would probably argue that he like his
he almost sees his science as like a
calling as like a
it's like it's almost like his vocation
you know and like right
he finds meaning spiritual meaning and
purpose through his scientific work
right yeah and i i kind of see both
sides of that
those two arguments too you know like
like part of me
like i think that i really like origins
of life research because
of my background right i think it's
really i think it's really fascinating
and
it does raise a lot of interesting
questions and i like exploring that i
like diving into that
space you know i'm just really curious i
like i like big questions
um right but also you know like i work
with
people no faith you know unsure
all other faiths you know i work people
from
all different backgrounds and i don't
think you
like i don't think that you have to have
a faith
to like find meaning in your science
either right right you know
i think there's i think there's value in
the work no matter where you come from
well if you look at the history of
science in the west
um and all of our history books if you
read on science it's totally skewed
towards
you know europe but uh the
the tradition there was it was a
christian tradition where people were
they're like okay there's the bible
that's god's word and then there's
the actual universe around us that's
god's creation so
we can we can worship god by studying
creation
and they they're it was it was through
that uh
that mindset that they became very
strict with you know we need to
demonstrate every
every claim needs to be demonstrated by
observations
you have uh nullius and verba which came
about that was the
the slogan for the royal society and
that means take no one's word
so they would they were super strict
because
they realize it's really easy to
misinterpret um
observations in the universe and people
mission
you know people people fight over how to
interpret the bible and that's just
you know written in you know normal
language imagine
how hard it should be to interpret
nature so
it was that it was actually under that
it was that christian um perspective
that was driving a lot of people
obviously not everyone at that time and
so yeah it it's it's not a surprise to
me to hear that you find
that there's a sort of a calling in in
uh
your science for you and
that with stephen j gould's
non-overlapping
you know his argument you know he argues
that the
science and religion don't overlap but
of course if you look at just how people
deal with science and religion
it for a lot of people it does right for
a lot of people
uh yes so it's you know i think i think
gould's idea was like uh
like i don't know maybe wishful thinking
is one way to say it or maybe he was
proposing how it should be
but obviously if you look at how how
people actually deal with this it's not
how it works
and so it's yeah i'm i've been really
interested in biologos
which is this group that you know set up
this forum to talk about
evolution in the in the christian world
and yeah i'm really interested in and
all the conversations i've had with you
have been really fascinating on this
topic too so yeah
i'm really glad to have you here uh
talking about this
yeah your uh your mention of
interpretation is really important
you know and that actually brings me
back to i had
one of my other really great teachers
that i had at that religious school when
growing up
he was actually a bible teacher and
um but i think he has like he has some
connections like
science maybe he may have maybe grew up
in like a science family or something
and um you know i i had him in high
school
and he told me he told uh he told my
class he said you know like
um you know like every everything that's
written in the bible
is translated you know if at times like
a lot of
especially a lot of the old stories were
passed down verbally before they were
ever written down
right and then they were translated and
re-translated and a lot of the priests
would like
like change things as they like like
when they were translating it because
they interpreted something differently
you know
and um well just just plain telephone
you know yeah exactly right yeah and you
know and what that was
that was the cultural norm back you know
like that was not
that was not a problem right yeah and um
that was how information was passed
and um you know i
i guess that he he helped me realize
that
you know like the importance of
interpretation and a lot of times
religious persons told me
the bible says this right and even at a
younger youngest age i was like where
show me right and when they show you
you're like well
does it you know like it kind of says
this to
you like you could you could take this
multiple ways right and in truth you
know and
like a religious religious textbook like
the bible is really a combination of a
bunch of books
written by tons of people and sometimes
the bible says different things on the
same issue
and you have to like weigh like your
fine nuance or
like or maybe it doesn't come to a
consensus on this issue it just
it just wrestles with the conflict on
something right um
and being being not afraid to embrace
that and
like looking for more complex answers
than just
it says this right um i think that was
real that was actually something really
important for me
again that didn't happen in a science
class right but
affected how i interpreted things and
and also
like going back to the kind of
interpretation on nature
and relating it to you know religion um
[Music]
you know like saying how you like when
you said
you know you think of like if you know
if nature was created
and however it was created right um you
know like that
you think it would some have some type
of reflection on
the entity that created it right right
and that
that like and learning about that would
would
mean that you're learning about its
creator um
i think that i think there's a lot
personal like from my personal opinion
right i i can't speak for anybody else
but
um i think that's a really important
idea too you know and
i i tell my students um
you know like i'm i'm not a genius you
know like i
um if if god if a god or
if god like in whatever form you believe
exists right i'm sure that god is smart
enough
to answer my stupid questions right like
i'm never going to ask a question that
like stumps god
right right so yeah yeah you know right
you know like i'm
i'm not going to like like i'm not smart
enough to do that and in truth you know
darwin had a um i'm sure you probably
heard of darwin's quote on matters like
this he said
you know like he he felt like he was a
dog
like it would be like a dog um thinking
about the mind of newton
right you know like right like like
i i like personally i am religious and i
believe that my god can handle my
questions about the origin of life or
about space
about existence about anything right you
know
dinosaurs right yeah and in a sense like
i feel i find that very freeing
and uh you know i i feel like i
i can explore different questions and
nothing that i find is going to
like it's going to be like oh my gosh
i'm going to have this like crisis of
faith
because now i discovered this right you
know like yeah like
yeah and that that's my that's my
perspective you know i know
i know other people have different
thoughts on that yeah that's cool
so i i we've gotten a couple questions
from live viewers here
and i just wanted to address these real
quick before i before we move on
but we got uh um
otis asks gene's first metabolism first
or is that a false dichotomy yeah that's
a great question actually so i
um before beforehand i made a little
note of things that was
i was wondering topics that would come
up and that was actually one of them our
metabolism first replication
um yeah i mean that
in my opinion i think that there's room
for both of those
areas of research right you know i i
think it's much too early to know
for sure um and in truth um
i guess i think that the origins of life
feel like
different people sometimes have
different like their own
theories on how things worked but i
think there's space
for all these ideas right i just don't
think we're far enough along
to be able to say gene first or to be
able to say metabolism first you know i
think that there's really cool working
going on work going on in both
both fields and to
to kind of just like like put one away
and focus on the other one i think would
be a huge mistake
and so um yeah especially at this point
yeah
yeah you know my personal opinion um
you know i would i would guess i guess
that i would i work
my research is kind of more in the rna
slash peptide kind of come like combined
world first right um
and you know like when you look at the
ribosome like how rna
and you know like short peptides are
really kind of at the heart of it right
yeah um and uh like
somebody like lauren williams at georgia
tech is really like a pioneer in that
field
um you know i i think that that idea has
a lot of potential merit to it
but i'm completely open to metabolism
first also
right you know when you yeah um i
i personally would not argue one or the
other set hard
yeah i just want to spend a few seconds
here explaining what this what this
means for people that
might not understand so the metabolism
first idea is this idea that some aspect
of metabolism that that cells are using
today
uh may have came before genes
and so it's it's kind of uh
it's kind of weird to even ask
metabolism first versus gene first
because
you know obviously there was not a full
cellular metabolism before there were
genes
uh i mean and there were not modern
genes
in the start so whatever we're looking
at in the origin of life
it's there's going to be like
hints of what there is today but it's
going to be very different so and
and you can actually kind of define any
any sort of chemistry as
metabolism if if molecules are being
transformed from one thing to another
so it's it gets a little bit tricky and
because of that i've actually
been working with uh greg springsteen on
a video about the metabolism first
hypothesis
and that's going to be published as soon
as this paper gets approved
for publishing i've got the video almost
ready right now and so
probably in the next hopefully in the
next couple of weeks
we will have a full video on that
explaining that whole
perspective what's even meant by
metabolism first
so yeah i'm i'm very excited and i've
been i've been thinking about this for
months now
so yeah that's a great question yeah
yeah and then the other question
was from the higher evolutionary
they ask john and dr j
can you both touch on your religious
peers
view of your academic experience so
um i mean i i'm i'm not religious jay is
my but i do have lots of religious peers
like my
uh my family is is religious
but i'm gonna turn that over to you so
sure um right so my um
my i mean my family is very religious
right um
my co my coworkers i would say you know
some of them are some of them are not
um in terms and researchers in the
origins field
i would say you know perhaps a majority
would
probably declare themselves agnostic or
atheist but not
not a huge majority right i think
there's a there's a lot of religious
persons
that work on these types of problems
just like me right oh yeah yeah
at the center there's a lot yeah there's
i yeah i mean i won't i won't name
specific names just
for the privacy but i you know i i could
i could go down the list very quickly
and a lot of people very prom
very prominent ordinance life
researchers yeah um
i've never had anyone ever at least
to my to my face make fun of me or
anything for my views
um right um you know
i think most i think if you talk to most
scientists
they would they would say the there's
accepting of scientific like current
scientific thought
or think you know like well-established
theories like evolution and things like
that
like if you do that like we're good you
know
like you know like i can have my
personal other views and you can have
yours
right but if you accept the basic
science
like for what it what it is right i
think most scientists are happy with
that you know yeah
because in truth you know like you know
i think one just needs to look at the
united states now right is
there's a lot of people that don't
necessarily accept basic science for
what it is right yeah
yeah um and so that you know i think
that's
that's our common denominator right and
you know i like they're
they're i'm sure that there are some
hardcore atheists that
wouldn't agree with the fact that i can
be religious and still be in order as a
life scientist but i feel like that
number would be very small
actually yeah yeah you know in the
meetings that i've been to
with at with the center how many people
work in the center for chemical
evolution
um i'd say in terms of like all like
students and postdoctoral
fellows and professors and things you
know probably a hundred
yeah maybe more yeah and so when we go
to these meetings
topic of religion comes up sometimes at
the bar
after meetings um but it's it's always
very it's always been
really respectful whenever because
because there there are a lot so there's
you know at the center you've got a
pretty good mix of religions too you've
got
i was there for one day one time i was
during lent
and so it was super obvious who all was
catholic because you know
they were asking ordering fish
but then the um there's there's quite a
few
i guess you'd say protestants is that
how you would if you had to categorize
yourself when you say you're protestant
yeah so you know i i would say that i
grew up
evangelical i would say that i'm no
longer evangelical
i'm a mainline protestant okay
yeah yeah yes and then and then there's
you know we
you've got hindus yeah quite a few
hindus at the center
you've got some yeah and several several
other people
and i've spoken with that uh they
practice various
either eastern religions or traditional
uh more traditional kind of
folk religions too so and then of course
there's there's a healthy chunk of
atheists
uh at the center but the
yeah every everybody
i i was really impressed with the center
because
there was a documentary i think was by
nova or something that came out a while
ago about origin of life research
and the whole thing was just
interviewing people independently and
they all
seemed to hate all the other researchers
this was done back in
probably in like the 90s or something
and
you know they were interviewing
different labs that were that were
studying
conflicting ideas and
they were just they were they're very
mean to each other
and i i kind of figured that this field
was going to be like that and that's not
the case at all like it was
you know my my first encounter with the
center was with nick hud who's the
director
uh and then ron krishnamurthy uh and
then i started going to the meetings and
it's like wow this this whole group is
i mean people have heated scientific
debates quite
quite often but it's uh it's it was a
very
it kind of felt like a almost like a
family group it was really neat
coming in and and seeing the center and
seeing seeing what you guys are doing
so it still feels like a family they're
like my science family
yeah seriously you know like i feel that
way and
um so this year is actually the last
year of the center for chemical
evolution right
so national science foundation grants
like that have a 10-year period
that so you can get up to 10 years of
funding and they permanently sunset
those
so that they can fund new projects and
new like new endeavors and things like
that which i think is very important
you know it it's important to mix it up
you don't want to just work on one thing
forever um yeah or at least fund
one thing forever right you know like
there are there are so many other
problems that big problems that need
basic science research and so um i'm not
necessarily mad that it's being
sunsetted but i am a little like
personally a little disappointed you
know these are my you're right these
this is my science family you know i've
i've been working collaborate
collaborating with these people for six
years
that's a long time and um we we've done
made some really cool discoveries but
you know i've
made a lot of good friends and some of
my
best career mentors are still like or
that's where we met right you know these
are people who helped me get my job
and when i like write grant proposals
like
you know like right like they'll like
you know like if we're going to
collaborate on a grant they'll like
write a letter of support you tag on the
end saying like
i'm going to work with jay and we're
going to do this right yeah you know and
so those
those connections are going to last long
after the cce does
right and so we're going to like i'm
going to continue to work with people
um after we're done i'm sure and even if
we don't necessarily like work on a
paper together you know i'm still going
to
ask them hey i wrote this can you take a
look at it and review it or
like kind of like give me edits or
comments or um hey like
my friend um my friend is looking for a
job in this field do you know anybody
who
might like might want them you know
things like that like
those those connections are going to go
my time my entire scientific career
yeah yeah i we're getting a lot of
technical
it's like more science related questions
here
and i want to let's see
there was there was another question i
had though before we get into the
technicalities of everything well
so a lot a lot of people are asking
about specific hypotheses like the warm
little pond
um that was the warm little pond is just
a letter that darwin wrote um
i can't remember who he's writing it to
but i think it was
uh joseph hooker if i remember correctly
okay yeah botanist
right and uh so that was just
darwin just supposed you know maybe life
got started in a warm little pond with
you know the chemistry in there
being just right and actually you're i
would say that
some your your wet dry cycle work is
pretty much
in in that model right yeah yeah so
but do you want me to talk about that a
little bit yeah yeah just here in a
second but i i just kind of
to give people kind of a basic overview
we
you you'll hear things about like the
rna world hypothesis
and you know jay mentioned today there's
a combined
peptide rna world hypothesis
that a lot of people are now paying more
attention to so the idea that
short proteins tiny little proteins were
being produced naturally in the
environment
along with small chains of rna or
something similar to rna
a lot of people are studying proto-rna
now yeah
and that these different types very
different types of molecules
we're acting in some sort of symbiotic
way that
ended up ended up being beneficial for
both of them and
kick-starting what we now know as life
so the the ribosome
the core the the structure inside the
cell that
reads genes and uses that information to
build proteins
that structure is made out of rna with
little proteins
giving it its structure and so
we think well how do you how would you
get something like this to originate
well you
you need rna or something similar to rna
and you would need short proteins or
something similar to short proteins
that are finding each other in this
environment attaching to each other
and forming various shapes until you get
one that's
just like this this ribosome that can
actually
help build proteins so
the there the thing that we
don't well actually i should probably
just just ask you this
uh what would you say is the big
unanswered question about the origin of
life the big thing that if we could
answer this
one question everybody would open up
their champagne
and laboratories all around the world
origin of life laboratories
and we might even be like okay we've uh
we've solved
the origin of life to a a degree that's
satisfying
what what would that what would that
question be
yeah um yeah that's a that's a good
question you know
honestly i think there's multiple things
that would be like that
right i don't think there's just one um
i think one of the biggest ones
is it has to do with replication
right and like molecular like true
molecular evolution
right so starting you know starting with
these simple building blocks
and having them self-assemble into
something like
the rna right and then having
like something just really simple in
that is basically like a self-replicator
where it can make copies of itself
and keep that information going right
right um
so i think open-ended evolution yeah i
think we're making a lot of progress on
that front
to be honest but um i think there's a
long ways to go
um i think that would be a really that
would be a huge hit
yeah yeah um and that that's what i hear
from most people so
uh when i when i it's it people are
looking for
a system that's prebiotically plausible
so it could have happened
on a lifeless planet and gives rise to
a system capable of open-ended darwinian
evolution so it's it's evolving through
descent with modification
acted upon by by natural selection
because
if you have a truly open-ended system
then you can get things like symbiosis
to evolve you can get things like the
genetic code to emerge the genetic code
is this
communication system between really the
the
the genome and the ribosome and so long
as you have
darwinian evolution going you we know
how symbiosis
evolves we know how cooperation evolves
we know how all these things happen so
if you can get a system capable of
darwinian evolution open-ended
darwinian evolution then then life is
it's on its way right yeah so i think
the ribosome
it's itself and think i think that's
that's a huge area of um
huge importance i mean that's an area of
huge importance and too
um you know the the idea to have
encoded information and like
taking all those letters of rna
and expressing out kicking out those
little amino acids and stitching them
together to make
proteins which are basically the
machines of life right you know proteins
are
what we call enzymes right when you take
a drug that drug molecules interacting
with
a protein right um that's they basically
carry out the functions of life in all
life that we know at
like you know like little worms and
little microbes and us
you know that um and so i think the
ribosome itself is also very important
and um it i think
it's so the the middle the middle part
of it is such
a it's almost like a chemical fossil
right
now like the core of the ribosome the
core of the ribosome that's right
and it basically tells it almost tells
us about like
what mole those molecules were for
what we call luca like the you know like
the oldest common ancestor
that we have right right because all
organisms today
except for viruses have ribosomes but
viruses use our ribosomes that's
that's why viruses are inherently ours
they have to use them
yeah yeah um yeah so i mean and the
whole question of
is a virus alive right so i'm that's an
interesting question on its own
i'm teaching an origins of life class
this fall to college freshmen
and i'm going to make them write papers
and argue
whether coronavirus is alive or not
that's pretty i think that'll be fun
yeah so so so that you know
p there's a lot of people that want to
get that that
they're going to be satisfied and even
like maybe even
be like okay we're done doing this
research if you can get to an open-ended
evolving system that is prebiotically
plausible others want to get all the way
to
a ribosome or an analog to the ribosome
so that
this this um to get information transfer
between unlike
molecules yes and but but those are kind
of the two
those are like the two big things that i
hear mostly when i'm talking to original
life
chemists yeah i mean i i do think that
the metabolite you know i think that
metabolism
field also has some potential big hits
um
you know being able to um you know like
when we think of
like really kind of fundamental
biological cycles like the
citric acid cycle right yeah um like
people like greg springsteen are
basically trying to kind of come up with
like a simplified version
of their own where they can like go
around the cycle multiple times and
and reproduce you know these like
molecules coming in and out
i think that's i think that's huge
honestly i think that's really cool
yeah so so in the comments i'm getting a
lot of stuff about specific like
people asking about hydrothermal vents
warm little pond
and one of the things that i i would
just say on that is that
we have
it's it's not i don't i don't think it's
super helpful to
get wedded to a specific micro
environment
where the origin of life happened right
now we're still exploring chemistry and
thinking we're trying to figure out what
types of reactions can produce the
things that are
eventually able to evolve and when we
really found a system
that can work then we would worry about
what type of
specific micro environment can actually
cause that to happen i think it's
kind of like a it's a distraction to
worry
about that right now because we're not
we don't have a model that works start
to finish so
to to try and say what specific you know
did it happen on
earth did it happen on a meteorite did
it happen in a pond or
at the bottom of the ocean um i guess
those things are
interesting to think about but maybe a
little bit of a distraction
i don't know what your thoughts i would
argue that we should study all of those
things yeah right you know i think that
again like focusing on one of those
environments is too narrow and we just
we the truth is we just don't we just
don't know a lot
about those early earth environments you
know like we
we've learned a lot recently but there's
so much more we don't know
you know like the um you know like the
early earth was likely
um you know like it likely had a
different atmosphere
right um you know we we think that maybe
the oceans were a little more acidic
it might have been hotter you know
there's a lot of volcanism
like a lot of a lot of like meteorite
falls and things like that but like
i'm yeah i mean and and i'll be the
first person that i am not a geologist
so um but you know it's you know
it seems like there's a lot we don't
know about the early earth and so
to like you said to kind of focus on one
environment right now i think is
maybe the wrong idea i think but but
also like i think if you know
if people have expertise in hydrothermal
events then they should focus on that
that's their
that's their expertise right and then
yeah if people have focus
like an expertise and more like warm
little pond
like the research i do is more of like a
one little pond i would argue
um yeah but yeah i'm you know i'm open
to all those ideas
well i think that i think so go ahead i
would say the reason it can be a
distraction is because the early earth
just like modern earth
was a huge place with millions of
environments and so if
if we can get our clues from the
chemistry itself i think that's probably
the best way to go right now
i mean that that's where i would spend
my energy i think
because there are millions of possible
places you could look
like micro environments you could study
and try and simulate in the lab it
almost doesn't
it's like uh you're just throwing darts
at a board kind of
so so that that's why i think that
really focusing on the chemistry what
types of
temperatures are needed to get
you know uh rna to
bind with you know uh with its uh
with its counterpart and and things like
this are are
these are the type of of questions
that i think are most helpful uh that
the center seems to be focusing a lot on
and and it seems like that's what that's
what greg's work is really doing when
he's when he's looking at metabolism
first
he's looking at okay these are the
reactions that cells do today
uh can we get those to happen without
enzymes without biological
molecules controlling all these
reactions
uh yes or no the answer is yes
what are the you know ph and temperature
requirements
and so doing that you can actually then
show
show those requirements to a geologist
and say hey which types of environments
could do this
and then and then you can simulate those
environments and so there's there's this
this kind of back and forth um that you
can do
to get to get to get at these answers
you know it's like doing a puzzle that
if you
if you just focus on one little spot
you're not going to find all the pieces
you kind of need to go wherever you're
you're finding
pieces that fit together kind of build
out from there
and there's right now i'd say there's
not uh
and we don't we don't have a system that
works start to finish it's kind of all
over the place
um in in origin of life but i'm
i'm seeing this kind of puzzle fill out
and
different aspects of it are connecting
with each other and it's been really
really cool to see even just
over the few years i've been working
with the center i've seen just things
fill out really nicely
yeah i'd like to add a couple quick
things to that first of all you know
when you think of like a
hydrothermal vent versus a one little
pond or a meteorite right yeah
all three of those environments like
it's it's
very it's very easy to to
figure out how a molecule like an amino
acid could form
in any of those environments right you
know and so like a lot of the building
blocks
of life as we know it here on earth you
know a lot of those
small molecules kind of have almost like
a universality to them
right you know like like a lot of the
amino acids that are in
you and i can are formed on meteorite
like form outer space and they're like
transfer on meteorites
and when they fall to earth like when we
drill in there and analyze them like a
lot of them have
amino acids right and so you know the
idea that
like i like what you said about kind of
like
focusing on like the more fundamental
chemistry because
i think that there are fundamental
chemistry processes associated with life
that could have happened in any of those
environments or all or
or maybe happened in all of them right
yeah and i think that also
has interesting implications for our
search for life elsewhere
through like nasa missions and things
like that right like what are we looking
for
when we send probes to different planets
and moons and things
um yeah cool
i've got one more question uh people are
asking about james tour do you know
who james tour is um he's been
outspoken he's a he's a chemist at
rice university who he's not he's not an
origin of life chemist but he uh
he goes and he does speaking tours at
churches saying that it's it's all
it's all a bunch of garbage and so yeah
so i've actually talked with james
because he used um
he was using okay turns out he was not
using it but
he he was on a video done by the
discovery institute which is the
intelligent design group
in the group in kentucky or i think
they're in
seattle washington actually okay but
they
they they've done a video about how the
origin of life is all fake and it's that
scientists are
in a conspiracy to you know trick the
public into thinking that
the origin of life has already been
figured out it's like fake moon landing
stuff
which is hilarious because you know if
the scientists studying the origin of
life trick the public into thinking the
problem's already solved they're going
to lose their funding
because yeah so anyway it's not already
solved i'll i'll be there
i'll admit it right no the origin of
life is an unsolved mystery that's why
people are
so interested in it so um but he had
he had used well he didn't use it the
the the video took a chunk of one of my
animations and completely quoted it out
of context
they they made it look like i was saying
that they um
a an abiotic membrane was a living cell
and and and then james tour was making
fun of that idea
and it was the way they'd edited it all
together so it made me think that james
had
had like seen my entire video and was
specifically talking about that so i
actually he and i talked we probably
talked for like an hour
um but he has had uh
i mean he he he's in a mindset that if
origin of life can happen naturally then
his religion is doomed
um i mean he doesn't say that if you ask
him
but but he his his actions
his actions suggest that and talking to
him
you know you said that you've had a
positive experience even working with
atheists and so on
uh like he had a genuinely bad
experience with that
um and i think that's that's really uh
colored his his view on this and and i
have heard i've had i've heard that
people
that you know honestly
i have i have people cry persecute
people had to cry persecution
sometimes even when it's not warranted
but that there are some stories that
i've heard where people really do get
picked on
in serious ways even in career-ruining
ways
because of their religious ideas that's
definitely happened before and
uh something similar to that um
i mean i don't want to put words in his
mouth he's not here to talk about it but
uh like he's he's definitely had some
problems in the past
with the secular community in science
and
so i i can kind of understand his
frustration but his
the arguments that he makes he's not an
original life chemist
he he he really
pretends to be in his talks and it's
it's kind of
disturbing to see him do that but he's
the arguments that he's making really
come from ignorance he
he's he's not he's not uh familiar with
the literature
and when i was talking to him about this
um you know he had made a statement that
there was no progress
an origin of life since the miller yuri
experiment and i sent him a bunch of
papers
and um he said okay well i hadn't seen
this i hadn't seen that so
um anyway i don't know i don't know what
his future is going to be if he's going
to continue doing that but it's it is
quite
obnoxious because he's he's posting
these videos on youtube and stuff but
anyway i don't want to get derailed by
yeah i don't want to speculate on
someone i don't know anything about
and so yeah so yeah i i am very much
aware that guy like he and i have spoken
and we actually spoken several times but
and he he does
really good uh chemistry outreach too he
had really good stuff
actually before i started doing online
education
i bumped into his work he was doing he
was creating
he was synthesizing these molecules that
were the shape of people
and he would use that to to get kids
excited about chemistry so he was
he had a whole video series on youtube
about chemistry that was really cool
so it's unfortunate to see that he's
like you know
kind of has this bitterness now because
he really is
he's good at what he does he's a
synthetic chemist and he's he's done
some really cool stuff
so i want to talk about
yeah kind of the meat and potatoes of
your research really with
the depth of peptides and the wet dry
cycles which again you're saying is kind
of the warm little pond
that's the type of environment that
would cause these to happen and uh
i might interrupt you a little bit to
try and you know
when we start to get a little bit too
jargon rich i think even like words like
peptide
can be confusing so i like to talk about
chains of molecules
instead of peptide and so on so yeah
let's let's dig in
to this um and really how is this
how was your research addressing this
larger question of how
how do we get evolving molecules like
right open and there when you see um
when you think of biology right um
you know biology is really just kind of
sys like a system of chemistry on a
grand scale
that can re reproduce and evolve and
things like that right so
biological molecules include things like
dna which most people are familiar with
right dna is the information storage
of life right and then you have rna
which
rna is basically like the transition
between
the stored information and proteins
which is which basically are the
machines of life right so rna
is what kind of reads um the dna
and kicks out and like leads to like
through the ribosome
kicks out proteins right and then you
have
other like small molecules we have
things like
um fats right people a lot of times call
those lipids right and they
make up the walls of our cells like we
call them membranes right
and you know they're all other kinds of
biological molecules but kind of the
um you know kind of like the holy grail
of biology is like like dna
rna and protein right yeah um and then
um
yeah and so i study how proteins could
have
chemically evolved before there were any
ribosomes which were the machines that
make proteins
that we all have in our bodies now right
yeah um and so
proteins are long chains
of amino acids which are these little
small molecules right
yeah um and um amino acids are
actually thought to be have been
ubiquitous on the early earth right
so amino acids form very easily
through really simple chemical processes
they're delivered
to earth from meteorites which probably
happened a lot more
back on the earlier than it does now but
it still happens now actually
yeah um and so these molecules that are
thought to have been at almost
everywhere
on the early earth right um and they
would have been produced
in various environments on the early
earth as well right so yeah it's not
just coming from
right yeah yeah that's right and so like
like they they would have actually been
formed on the early earth in addition to
have been delivered right and um i mean
some some of them even form in like
like space dust clouds right right you
know these
these are really like simple fundamental
molecules um of the universe
that as we know it and so um we used to
think they were unique to life and that
that was that was the big
discovery with the military experiment
is we were like how on earth does
anything like this be created because
it's so specific
and then when now we're now we now know
uh oh they're they're everywhere yeah
yeah
and so um so what i'm interested is
kind of the reverse process is taking
all the little amino acids and stitching
them together to make
chains of protein yeah right without any
biological machinery
involved yeah and so that's actually a
tricky problem
and so when you put amino acids
in water right they don't just naturally
stick together and and link up right
make this like long chain
yeah and um and so what we do is we do
like going back to that idea of darwin's
warm little pond is
we throw amino acids in a little like a
little body of water and we evaporate
the water
you know you think of some like an
environment some like a tidal pool or
something where water would kind of come
and go on a daily basis like when it's
hot
the water goes down and when it's cool
at night the water comes back in when
it's high tide or something like that
right
and so um if you put amino acids in
water and evaporate the water
you can make little tiny chains but
sometimes the little chains will like
like they'll kind of like wrap around
and they'll get stuck and so they don't
really grow
much right and so that's kind of the
problem that my
my area of research is trying to trying
to fix and so what we've discovered is
if you take these other molecules that
look almost identical to amino
acids but they only have one little
difference and in those like stanley
miller type experiments they form
alongside amino acids like so both both
these type both types of molecules
are present in those model prebiotic
mixtures and they're also
for both present and meteorites like
those same chemical mechanisms
uh that make amino acids also make these
you know it just depends on things like
the acidity or basicity or things like
that
so so so we find amino acids and we find
these are called
alpha hydroxy acids or hydroxy acids
right yeah
and so and life does not use them right
so well actually no
no it's not true and so they're not used
to make protein
right but um like one of the most common
ones i use is called lactic acid or
lactate
yeah right like when you work out you
probably have heard people talk about oh
you have too much lactic acid buildup in
your muscles right that has to do with
um it's like your metabolism right
but lactate is actually is a biological
molecule
right and so um the molecule lactate
looks just like an amino acid called
alanine
the only difference is one has an o h
like an oxygen and the other one has an
nh2 which is the nitrogen right that's
the only difference everything else is
exactly the same
and so uh going back to around 2014
we had um actually ron christian murthy
who you mentioned earlier was the one
who
uh kind of one of the originators of
this idea you thought hey
what if we took these hydroxy acids and
amino acids and threw them together in
the pot right
and what if we evaporated the water then
maybe we could make longer chains of
like protein-like molecule right and we
found out that it did
and it actually works it works extremely
well and is
it i joke that i i am not a synthetic
chemist i'm actually
trained as an analytical chemist which
means i like separate out molecules and
figure out what different molecules are
yeah if i can make something
it's very easy right that's what i tell
people
my undergraduates do it on the first day
that they work in my lab right you
literally just throw them in water and
you heat the water
and when you put them back when you add
more water back
right and you take them all you dissolve
the molecules and you analyze them you
have all these different chains
it's really that simple right so let me
try and
uh back up here a little bit to give a
little bit more perspective to people
that are way outside of this field so
the um for a long time we've known that
amino acids which are the building
blocks of proteins those can be produced
on the early earth
just fine and there's lots there's
hundreds of different ways they can be
produced
and they're not generally produced in
high concentrations but
they are produced we're also getting
these um
sorry what was the name of the molecule
again that hydroxyl hydroxyl hydroxy
acids right
we're also getting hydroxy acids
produced alongside of them and we just
assumed that that was just garbage just
junking up the uh the mess that the
prebiotic environment can produce
and in a lot of in the past
a lot of these origin of life
experiments we would
we would look at what types of molecules
were available and then we would
because just like when you're trying to
put together a puzzle you're not trying
to
do the whole thing at once you just take
baby steps people were taking
pretty high concentrations pure
concentrations of amino acids and seeing
what they do
can these interact with each other and
make uh
peptide chains can they can they make
little protein chains
and the answer was frustratingly no like
they just keep on producing these little
dead end particles and so
rom is like well let's just make it
dirtier let's make it dirtier like in
real life
and throw on these other molecules and
see what happens and when that happened
you were getting these chains to form
now uh those chains
the reason that we think they're cool is
because
they can fold up into three-dimensional
shapes and they can act as enzymes they
can a lot of them won't do anything at
all but some of them
can happen to have enzymatic properties
and depending on their sequence
they're going to fold up in a particular
shape and
they're going to have a specific
enzymatic uh property and so they can
dramatically transform the types of
chemistry that can
now happen in that environment that you
get an emergence of new
properties just by creating a chain of
of protein instead of having individual
amino acids
so that's why this is something we've
been wanting to do for a long time
and your research found a way to do this
so well
yeah so i i will i will just give a
caveat to that so
we are right now what we're trying to do
is
look at their kind of behavior and their
activity or like at like working as
enzymes right and so
we we feel like we've come up with one
one way that life could have or like
that
like prebiotic chemistry could have made
little protein chains
right you know like there's there are
other ways other other researchers are
working on this problem also
um and i guess now kind of a direction
that we want to take is
let's start looking for function like
can these things like you said like fold
up and actually do
like carry out processes and things like
that right
and so that that's really where we want
to go next yeah
so but right now you've just been asking
the question can nature build these
um and now that the answer seems to be
yes
i mean obviously this is prebiotically
plausible in pyrex so
you know it's happening in the lab but
but it does seem prebiotically plausible
now
um and of course you know
there's people debate on what that what
that means and how you can really
demonstrate that but
the um so so now you guys are looking at
function
how long are the are the chains you're
getting these depth c peptide chains so
it's a combination of amino acids and
yeah how long are they how long are they
getting yeah so let me
let me give some perspective first right
so like proteins
in life today they so
johnny mentioned the term peptide a
peptide is a really short protein
right they're the same thing and so um
like we have we have peptides and
proteins in our body that carry out
functions that are really short
you know just a couple amino acids long
and they like
some of the peptides in our brain that
do deal with brain chemistry are
actually very short
um and we have huge giant you know
million
amino acid like like maybe not a million
but like
like you know tens of thousands i mean
like giant yeah protein complexes right
i think there is one in the muscle cells
that is over a million i could be wrong
but yeah i mean
right so the the the size and scale of
proteins
is i mean it's it's logarithmic
like it's like many orders of magnitude
difference right yeah
what's the smallest peptide we're
normally using
like it the biology uses i mean we have
ones that are just a few
residues long right and so you know like
like uh
like leucine and keflan is a
neuropeptide it has five
amino acids right yeah it's y g g f l
right okay and so um and they're short i
mean they're shorter ones than that too
right
and so yeah a lot of venom yeah
that's right tiny peptides yeah i would
say that the majority of proteins in our
body
are you know put like hundreds to
thousands of amino acids
maybe yeah right and so the the chains
that we're making
are not that long yet right and so
we're making ones that are you know like
20 like 15 20
25 residues at length at the most right
um but one of the things
so and a really important aspect of this
has to do with what's called solubility
right and so different molecules can
dissolve or not dissolve in different
solutions right
and so kind of the classic um and it has
to do with something called polarity
which is
are do molecules have um
like do they share their electrons
evenly across a molecular bond
right and so um there everybody says
light dissolves like so polar molecules
which do
which do not equally share electrons in
a bond
like water is a classic example of that
right and so everybody knows that water
is h2o
the oh the oxygen spends more time
holding on to electrons than the
two h's do right yeah and so that's a
that's what we call a polar molecule
where if you have something
like gasoline right get gasoline has a
lot of carbons and hydrogens but they
equally share electrons so that's
what's like called nonpolar right yeah
and so if you mix water and gasoline
they don't mix right they layer
they don't mix well together right and
so
um that's that's a really fundamental
idea in chemistry is understanding
things called polar like about polarity
and
how different molecules dissolve in
different liquids right right
and so um proteins are these really huge
chains
right and so how do you get a huge
molecule to dissolve in water
is like you said the protein has to fold
in on itself
and all of the polar parts of the
molecule are on the outside
because then they touch the water and
all the non-polar
parts are on the inside and they're like
hidden from water and a modern evolved
protein yeah in a modern protein that's
right and so
and so what drives that is in part in
large part
is the sequence of the protein right the
amino acids
themselves that are involved in in that
chain right
so different amino acids have different
polarities associated with them
and some of them dissolve better in
water than others or some of them like
water more than others right yeah
and so um one of the challenges that we
are facing and is
you know when we just take like a like
simple amino acids and put them in that
little wet dry pond
and kick out these molecules right is
when you have all of the same type of
amino acid or just like two types of
amino
acid um a lot of times they're not um
they don't have enough polarity for them
to dissolve well
as they get longer right the longer ones
tend to not dissolve in water so they'll
just float
or they'll like or they're like like
thick on the walls or things like that
right yeah
um and so what we really need to do is
we need to introduce
more complex mixtures of amino acids
including ones that are polar
so that we have enough polarity that
these things can stay in solution
as they get longer and longer longer
right and so the challenge of that is
more of kind of like an analysis problem
right and when you
when you throw in all these different
amino acids together you get these
really complex mixtures of molecules
right um that's what i love that's like
that's what i'm trying to do
so i'm i'm an analytical chemist so i
like to separate out all these things
and i actually we can we can sequence
the proteins using a technique called
mass spectrometry that's what i'm
trained in i'm a trained mass
spectrometrist
and so um we can use that technique to
actually
break apart the the little proteins
like amino acid by amino acid and read
the sequence that way
it's not it's not as quick and easy as
doing dna sequencing though
right right so dna sequencing
is genome sequencing is as much
you know you can read a whole human
genome now the tesla you know in just
minutes right
yeah um but there's only four
in dna right and rna there's only four
possible
monomers right and so in
modern proteins there's 20 amino acids
right but we think that on the earlier
there were way more than 20 amino acids
right we think they were
hundreds of possible you know or maybe
thousands of possible amino acids and
life just
ended up choosing 20 out of them yeah
right it's almost like a funnel like we
took
you know we started with this group but
then some of these were more effective
than others so we kind of honed in
and evolved on like the ones that we
really like to use right
yeah and so um i'm also interested in
making
little proteins with amino acids that we
we don't use in biology today
right i think i think that asks a lot of
interesting questions like what if we
make little proteins
of like weird amino acids and let's
compare how those
proteins work versus the ones that use
the ones that we use
in biology right and and we might find
that the 20
that biology uses was some sort of weird
accident or maybe there's
they work better for you know certain
certain situations and that's that's why
natural selection favored them yeah
yeah i mean people have made arguments
suggesting that our 20 amino acids are
kind of like an
optimized amount right you know i
i liken it to letters of the alphabet
right and so we have 26 letters in the
in the english alphabet and the number
of words you can
use you can make with that those 26
letters is effectively infinite right
um where if you had an alphabet of four
letters the number of words you could
make would not be as
good right yeah and so um
[Music]
really the power of proteins is the
ability to do all these different
behaviors based on their sequence of
amino acids right that's really
their strength but dna is dna is better
for
storing information though just because
it's it's a much
sturdier and um like
it's actually you know the fact you only
have four bases it's actually a good
thing
you know you don't want like too much
like too much information storage right
so
if things get more complex kind of as
you read the information and express the
proteins
you get a lot of noise yeah that so um i
just i just want to
hammer home this like how it is that
proteins work a little bit so
a protein in the body is a chain of
amino acids
the sequence causes it to fold in on on
itself
to form a glob and in a very specific
three-dimensional shape
i had someone ask earlier about the
chaperone proteins how would you get
proteins to eat to emerge without
chaperone
um molecules and uh
you know if if early on
a lot of proteins in our bodies today
they're actually their folding is guided
by other
other molecules that help them fold in a
proper way but if you don't have those
other molecules to help them fold in a
proper way
what's going to happen you'll get
misfolded proteins that end up being
garbage
and so you'll just have to make more
protein because a certain percentage of
them are garbage
so that would have been something that
evolved later on
but we're talking about small really
small
proteins you see you should you're
getting about 20 long or
12 between 12 yeah yeah right now right
i mean
i i think we have ideas in place already
to how to make them longer
and worse and more dissolvable yeah
still
right in a prebiotic setting yeah
yeah but we haven't done that work yet
you know that's something that we're
we're
interested in doing in the future yeah
and then the the other thing
so hopefully that's clear to everybody
and the other thing that i wanted to
point out is that uh
original life gets a lot of um criticism
for
using really pure chemistry because
obviously in the origin
in the origin of life there wouldn't
have been pure amino acids of any type
um ron christian murphy has really
pushed for dirtier chemistries
and it's because of people like you who
can do the hard analytics that's making
this possible in the past it was
it was just not possible to analyze a
dirty mixture
so you could you could make these
do these dirty chemistry experiments all
you wanted but there's no way to see
what the heck is going on in there
that's right and so it's it's recent
innovations and a lot of innovations
even at the center
for analyzing dirty mixtures of
chemicals to see what's happening
and this is this is a really cool time
in original life because we're just
starting to really look at
okay we understand how amino acids
behave
in you know essentially pure water what
happens when you add more garbage in
there more more
more chaos into the system and we're
actually seeing that it helps
more than hinders and and a lot of these
experiments like the one that you found
it was
it was adding what we thought was junk
into the system
that actually made these the system work
which is really cool
yeah and and i will say um as
personally because i'm in a chemist who
does all that
analysis i i like the complex mixtures
too right
i like things when they're a little
messy and it makes it more fun that way
in my opinion but i also do think that
there is
a real value in a place for kind of more
like reductionist
approaches yeah right where you just
take a simpler system and you really
like break it down to its components and
really understand the basics of how it
works and things like that
i think that there's room for all that
oh yeah yeah absolutely we need to
understand
how these interactions happen we need to
understand exactly
exactly what's going on and the only way
to do that is is pretty hardcore
reductionism right
yeah and i think the field you know i
think there's
there are certain kind of tensions that
all orders of life research deals with
right so like one of them is kind of
it was properly like metabolism versus
like
information storage right um one of them
is kind of like a more reductionist
approach which i would say
you know at times was maybe more common
um historically just because like you
said like we were limited in our ability
to analyze
those products and things yeah versus a
more like system view where
you things are messy right and it might
be more plausible from a prebiotic
standpoint but again when it's messy
it's
much harder right you know so you're
you're taking on
a lot of challenge when you make things
messy and that's still true i mean
that will always be true um and i would
say another one of those areas
is kind of like a bottom-up approach
versus a top-down approach right so i'll
explain what i mean by that so
a bottom-up approach would be starting
like
starting from the really building blocks
of molecules right starting from amino
acids and little like
bases and things like that can we make
protein can we make the rna can we make
molecules that look like them even if
they're not exactly the same right which
is kind of what we do
um or there's a top-down approach that
looks at biology
now right and try and and in particular
like what are the shared aspects of
all biology of life you know that we
think that those components would have
been
present in the that luca that that last
universal common ancestor
right and um kind of working your way
back down to more simpler things from
there right but there's a there's a gap
there right so we have this top-down
approach
we have this bottom-up approach but
there's there's a lot of space there in
the middle
right right and then truth is that's
you know that's where we have a lot of
area to grow you know because i
i i am more of a bottom-up chemist right
um but when you go to origins of life
research meetings
there are both top-down people and
bottom-up people you know
yeah um but the hard part is where do
those meet and we don't know
we don't know yet right and there are
people working at weird spots in the
middle too
but this is kind of wherever that
wherever there was a hint as to how
something might have happened
just like a puzzle it's growing out from
there and i i
to reiterate that you're saying that in
origin of life research
some people are really focused on bottom
up some people are looking at the cell
and looking
what's the most minimal type of cell and
then what's the most minimal evolving
system
and and we're trying to they're trying
to make predictions as to where the
bottom up needs to
eventually lead to right yes that's
right so yeah
yeah that's that's that's very important
uh
so so yeah it really is this like people
working on a puzzle from different
directions
to eventually meet in the middle and not
only do we not
have not only is there a gap in the
middle but
there's actually no good way to tell how
big that gap is
because we don't know that's right yeah
yeah it's probably huge
yeah yeah yeah so this is this is not an
an easy uh problem i i
it some people seem to think that it
should be easy like if it happened
in nature it should be easy but one of
the things i like to talk to people is
like you know
i learned to throw a basketball uh
into a hoop and that was that was easy
for me to do naturally
but to calculate what i'm doing and to
actually
scientifically describe what i'm doing
if you talk about neurotransmitters and
you talk about
just the equation of you know how how
does my brain calculate this and what's
going on
like i can't do that and um
that's a that's way harder and so the
the things that we're doing in origin of
life chemistry it's i mean it's
it it's a lot of work it's extremely
difficult
and it's extremely fascinating i i'm
just really
i love going and seeing what you guys
are doing
seeing the problems that you're dealing
with seeing how people are solving it
it's been absolutely fascinating to to
be to be
yeah yeah i'd like to i'd like to build
on that real quick so you know
i think that the argument that
everything needs to be easy i think
there is some truth to that but also
there's not right and so
um i do think that you know for
for some process to have been a
key part of the chemical evolution that
led to life
i think there needs to be an element of
universality to it right you know like
like i go back to
amino acids like amino acids are made in
outer space amino acids are made on
earth
um these are like really fundamental
molecules that form through simple
chemical processes but they're like
the end product of a lot of these roots
right
and so you know i think there is a kind
of a universality
event to that but also like you said
right it's it's not simple to find
something that is simple
right right right right like when you're
looking for something simple
usually what you find are a million
things that are really complex or like
are dead ends
right yeah and so that's that's where
the
that's the hard that's the hard work
right is um
you know finding these kind of universal
processes
and getting past all these other
processes that are not
right you know like that that's a that's
a really hard
hard pro hard thing to do and that i
think that's one of the biggest
challenges we face
as researchers in this field yeah i just
got a question
what can common people do to help
accelerate origin of life research
other than voting uh you know
so i i am one thing you can do folks
is you can like and share this video
but uh i don't do you have i don't i
don't want to derail
so if you just want to spend like 10
seconds on that like i don't want to
derail where we're going with that with
the chemistry here but
yeah i mean um i guess i'll i'll kind of
take a step back and just
argue that you know basic science
research has real value
right you know like it's super important
that the national institute of health do
cancer research
and do like mental health research and
all that like that's super important
right
but there needs to be enough of the pie
that we can do that
and we can still do basic science right
and i think some people would argue that
origins of life
science kind of falls in that basic
science category you know
i'm not trying to cure cancer i'm
working on
like kind of fundamental problem but
there are there are
tons of applications of what we do
outside the origin of life also right
yeah
and you know a lot of really basic
science has led to huge discoveries that
no one
had ever thought of 30 years prior right
and so
i think it's important just to you know
like
support i mean support canada to
fund basic science research right you
know i i think that's really important
and to emphasize to people that you know
even if my research doesn't
it immediately address something like
cancer or diabetes or something like
that that
that doesn't mean that it doesn't have
value right right
and we don't know when we're doing you
know the national science foundation
they exist
to fund projects that are not we don't
yet
know how they're going to be applicable
we don't know they're not directly
health related yeah and
and and we realized we needed to be
doing that because
i mean i think really world war ii was
it was cold war
yeah that's right and world war ii and
the cold war is the race
to the bomb and the race to space uh we
realized
oh we need to understand how the
universe works in order to even invent
as the starting points for all of this
and so uh
the national science foundation was like
okay we just want to fund
we want to set aside a chunk of
the u.s tax money for basic fundamental
research
and origin of life is you know falls
into that so you the the center for
chemical evolution is funded by the
national science foundation
and by and also partly by nasa yeah yeah
yeah so just to touch on the nasa
element right so nasa does
a lot does support a lot of origins of
life work too
because it's directly related to a lot
of their missions
to look for signs of life elsewhere
right
yeah you know or origins of life and
astrobiology are really intertwined
fields
right and um that like the experiments
that we do
help um people at nasa or
um you know people in like the european
space agency or whatever like when
they're designing a probe
to go to mars or to go to a
moon of jupiter or to go to a comet you
know like they're putting
little chemical instruments on on those
probes and
like they want to know like what are we
looking for right
like what molecules are we trying to
find right like what molecules are
important
and so and those conversations are
always changing and
you know like there's no set in stone
like
this molecule is a biomarker right right
you know people argue about what
biomarkers are
all the time right um that's not
that's not something that we've reached
a consensus on yet
yeah um but what we do is directly
related to that and so nasa does support
this kind of work as well yeah yeah
sorry i think i derailed you on the um
explaining your your your research but
we were
we were at the point where you were
saying that uh you know
you've we we know that we can make
peptide chains that are about 20 long we
think we can make them a lot longer
you're using much dirtier mixtures now
of amino acids you're exploring even
non-biological amino acids that the
types that
you know can be created in these
environments yes and
the next big step is to look at
functionality what what sorts of
what what can these things even do are
they folding up are they
able to catalyze other reactions and
then i i've gotten another question
about left-handed versus right-handed
amino acids
are you guys exploring dirty mixtures of
that as well and how that yeah that's a
great word that's a great question so
actually let me let me answer the
left-handed versus right-handed question
first
okay um because i i'm really interested
in that and so
for those of for those of you who don't
know so all of the amino acids and our
proteins
in biology are left-handed right and so
a lot of organic molecules have what's
called chirality your hand in this like
so it's basically just like your two
hands so
um my hands are essentially identical
but they're mirror images of each other
but i can't overlay them
without changing something right if i
overlay them this way i turned it around
yeah and so um they're
non-superimposable
kind of mirror images of each other
right and that's a really fundamental
property
in chemistry and also in biochemistry
right so
um biological amino acids are
left-handed in proteins
and you know like all the sugars in um
and uh in like nucleic acids are like a
certain hand in this as well right and
so
um so yes so we we actually do study
making these little chains with both
left and right handed amino acids
right yeah and that has implications for
how these fold
right um as like as the different bonds
go in different directions that changes
how things can fold
um it also can change how these things
can like self-assemble or like stick to
one another
yeah right how they can even kind of
aggregate um
and i think that's a really interesting
area of study and so
um because uh
abiotic amino acids like amino acids and
meteorites or
ones made by the miller uri experiment
most of them are
equal mixtures of left and right handed
right yeah and so
certain people are studying how we could
have kind of purified
like all just one hand of amino acid in
biology like and at what stage would
that have happened would that have
happened at the monomer level like when
they're just free amino acids would that
would happen when they're in the chains
themselves
you know and like some of the chains
like break down easier than other ones
yeah um we don't know but there's a lot
of really cool research going on that
there's a
a well-known chemist who i wouldn't say
is probably the world expert on
her name is donna blackman at the
scripps research institute
in um california yeah and she does she
does really cool stuff about
how like when amino acids uh
when they crystallize they when they
form solid crystals
like sometimes you can exclude like all
the left-handed ones or all the
right-handed ones
based on how they crystallize and form
solids really cool stuff
is going on in that field let me just
poke at this
to explain to maybe point out why this
is a problem
that needs to be solved is it because so
life today only uses 20 amino acids out
of hundreds of possible amino acids
yeah and then that but that hundreds of
possible amino acids is even bigger than
than just the hundreds because almost
all the amino acids come in two forms
they come in the left-handed form in the
right-handed form so that's right
so life uh if we want to get to
something like a modern
cell we need to explain how
we selected the 20 amino acids that life
uses
and the specific handedness of those 20.
and so that's a lot of explaining to do
right like because if you have
if you have a um a chain that
has more than just a normal 20 well you
just
increase the complexity like
your chances of getting two of those
chains to come about and an abiotic
reaction
is way is way smaller if you have more
than 20 amino acids
because we have way more than 20 amino
acids plus we also have
this handedness it seems almost
impossible that you'd ever get the same
two proteins to emerge
abiotically twice so if something was
really useful
well it's only going to be around for
a few reactions before it breaks apart
and then you'll never find that molecule
again
if it's if we're really starting from a
truly random uh starting starting point
so
some people think that maybe these
amount amino acids were filtered by the
environment
before they became chains other people
are looking into them being filtered
like the certain change will maybe a
maybe a chain built of
all left-handed amino acids will only
interact well
will will mostly interact with other
chains of left-handed amino acids
and so you can get you can get the
sorting to happen either before or after
chain formation yeah i think most people
in the field would argue that the
earliest proteins
and peptides and proteins like the
earliest chains probably had
mixtures of left and right-handed
monomers yeah but
maybe like the ones that were mixed were
not
as stable or maybe they were unable to
form
uh structures so protein they're they're
really common
um structural forms that areas of
proteins will make one is called an
alpha helix where it makes like it makes
like a turn
right and one's called a beta sheet
where it makes these like flat sheets
right and those are really fundamental
in all
proteins in biology and of life right
and
you know people argue well if you had
mixed left in right-handedness
you probably wouldn't be able to make as
good of those structures
and the proteins wouldn't be as stable
or they wouldn't be able to carry out
reactions things like that right
so that's one that's one thought in that
on that issue but it's a really that
field is
wide open you know there are a lot of
people are working on it but yeah
i think there's a lot of stuff we can
learn yeah yeah there's a lot of
possible solutions that i've seen that
are published but
there's no there's no agreement on what
actually was happening
yeah yeah um
all right and where were we on your on
your uh
your research maybe we're doing we are
doing research on that right
so we're like we're we're doing studies
about left and right-handed amino acids
when we make our
deficit peptide chains yeah so yeah and
and these depths peptides um
how much what what percentage of a chain
is amino acid versus
um i keep forgetting the name of the
other molecule hydroxy acid hydroxyl
that's
yeah that's actually a great question
and so one of the things we really like
about this
specific system is that so we call
the the way we make the chains we call
it wet dry cycling right so we put the
two types of
molecules in water we evaporate the
water
and then we add water back and we
evaporate the water and then we add it
back in these repeating cycles right
yeah and the more cycles that you do
the the content of the chains becomes
more amino acid
and less hydroxy acid so they
essentially
kind of convert to more like a
biological peptide or protein
as you do more of these wet dry cycles
and the reason for that
is that the the bonds that stick the
hydroxy acids together are not as strong
as the ones that stick the amino acids
together
right and the amino acids actually can
come in and replace a bond
that two hydroxy acids used to have yeah
and so the amino acids are kind of more
of the end product
and they're more stable over time which
um which is one reason why we think
right why would biology pick t amino
acids to form proteins and not these
hydroxy acids because the hydroxy acids
would break
those those chains would break down
easier right yeah they're not as stable
um but we actually see the content of
these chains
becomes more like biological proteins
over time as we repeat these cycles
that's really neat so it's just a heat
it's just an evaporation
and rehydration cycle that's it you're
literally adding water and
evaporating the water off like anybody
can do it yeah so like a
a puddle that forms with dew
and then evaporates during the day could
do this
yeah i mean this process probably
happens
on the earth now right we're just not
like you know we're not
doesn't really matter anymore you know
because yeah like
and also you know the earth earth
biology
like earth environments are so full of
biological molecules already right you
know like there's like
like just based on the the life
everywhere
on earth right yeah um that it would be
hard to tell the difference
and those molecules are eaten by
everything so you got a constant
yeah that's why you have to do these you
have to set up these labs that are
completely purified environments spend a
bunch of money on purifying water to
the craziest degree ever so there's no
like
uh ribozymes and stuff in it um
era rnas are i was working with a lab in
in corvallis and all their rna work
was not working like their rna wouldn't
wouldn't last at all
in their test tubes and it's because
they weren't purifying their water
enough they had a
rna and enzymes that were digesting rna
that just all living cells excrete
and so they're like why man this rna is
garbage it just
dissolves right away and it was because
they had
yeah everywhere on the planet earth
we find life and these biological
molecules so it gets really tricky
when you're doing these experiments to
try and purify that out
yeah um
trying to i think we've i think we've
kind of outlined your
work pretty well is there anything else
you really want to drive home
about your particular like something you
just love about your
your research that you wanted to mention
um
sure yeah so i i work at a i work at a
school where all my students are
undergraduates
right i don't have phd students that
work with me you know like a lot of my
collaborators that do at other schools
um
i really like working with college
students i think it's really fun
and um my the researchers in my lab you
know they're
usually 18 to 22. so they're quite young
and this is sometimes their first foray
into scientific research and so i think
it's really cool that they get to work
on
real origins of life chemistry problems
yeah you know just as college students
and it really uh kind of whets their
appetite for science
whether or not they go into research as
a career you know a lot of my students
have gone to med school
and things like that right yeah but um i
find that they really enjoy
doing basic science research yep that's
really cool
how do you get them caught up to where i
mean for like for me it took it probably
took a year or so
of reading books nick nick hud he
actually he was awesome he
bought me a bunch of books and sent them
to me just to kind of wrap your head
around
the current state of the field took
i really hours and hours i mean it was
it was months
of almost full-time work for me to to
wrap my head
on it you can't you can't ask a college
freshman or sophomore to do that right
away
you know i basically i i find something
for them to work on like i find a
research problem for them to work on
and then kind of give them stuff as they
go right you know
i teach them what they need to do to do
the they need to know to do the research
itself first
and then i can kind of build in some of
the background and
talk more about the field as we go um i
take them to our
scientific meetings right that's where
they learn a lot of the like what a lot
of what's going on in the field is
they actually sit in on other people's
talks and hear what they're researching
um that's really um that's really
helpful you know
it some scientific literature can be a
little
hard to approach for you know
college-stage students right
so soak an origin of life conferences or
yeah you know i mean
i mean that can be true that's true for
me sometimes you know i'll read
sometimes i'll read a paper where i'm
like i have no idea what's going on
um yeah and so i you know i i get them
started on the research itself
and explain their problem and then kind
of
show them things as they go along yeah
well
i i want to we're coming up on an hour
and a half here
and i want to you know be respectful of
your time but i i really wanted to
give you a chance one more time because
really
you are special in origin of life not
not just that you are a
a practicing christian and an original
life chemist but you're so open about
talking about it
and so i i was curious if you could tell
us just
what would you say to uh our christian
viewers that
are struggling with evolution and origin
of life science
what would be your you know two cents to
give to them on
how to deal with this but yeah you know
um
yeah i would go back to that idea that
that bible teacher
taught me when i was in high school is
that um
you know if you believe that your
religious texts like something like a
bible or whatever religion
you are you know has has real meaning
and real value
right um then you have to remember first
of all that
that if you're if you're having a
conflict about how
you read something or you believe
something and how it
gels or meshes with the science right
um you have to realize that you know
maybe the problem is how i'm
interpreting that
right you know maybe these two things
aren't fundamentally opposed to each
other maybe it's just
an inter i'm interpreting it that way
right yeah or maybe i'm missing
something
right um and
um being open to seeing
seeing your own beliefs with fresh eyes
and also being open to
[Music]
science itself right you know like the
idea that scientific research
you know if this this world this
universe
was created then it should tell us
something about
the entity that made it right and
um and there's like
those two things if if you're a
religious person right
you know if they if it seems like they
conflict
right and you know that happened like
you said that happens a lot right
um that means that maybe i'm
misinterpreting how i'm looking at my
religion
or in that religious text maybe i'm
misinterpreting the science
maybe i'm misinterpreting both i think
that happens a lot
right um but it doesn't necessarily mean
that those two entities themselves are
fundamentally opposed to one another
right it's usually i think a lot of time
it's interpretation and the and
i think that certain areas have a right
interpretation
right you know the science on evolution
is very clear
right i mean and one only needs to look
at
genetic testing right we can basically
trace the tree of life through genetic
testing right
yeah um right and so the evidence for
evolution is overwhelming
and it in a sense it's undeniable if you
look at the science itself right and so
typically when people have issues with
their with
crises of faith or things like that it's
really
it usually has to do more with the faith
and the science i
i would i would argue you know it's more
i think a lot of times
those hurdles that you have to get over
are maybe have to do with personal
theology
they have to do with how you're
interpreting religious texts you know
like
how you see how your religious world
view is
but um like on things like evolution the
signs are very clear
there are other areas where the science
is not necessarily
clear yet right you know like origins of
life science is an open field like we're
making huge
discoveries but we have a long way to go
but it doesn't mean that we won't get
there
and i think that that's a danger too
that sometimes religious persons will
fall into as they're like oh like
they're never going to figure this out
well you know maybe
maybe they will right and then if if
they do
you're going to have a crisis of faith
right but um
kind of people have i've heard people
call that like a god of the gaps
mentality right so like
we can't explain this gap in science so
god did it right well
you know like i think you need to be
careful with that idea
right um i guess just to summarize i
would just say
if if you have faith and you have
science right
i don't think these things fundamentally
oppose one another it has to do with
interpretation
and right and if you're
if the science is very clear and that
contradicts something of your faith
right then maybe you're maybe you're
interpreting something in your faith
incorrectly right yeah but it doesn't
that doesn't mean that your faith
necessarily has to just disappear right
um it could
right i mean that that's your that's
your prerogative right
um yeah but i don't i don't necessarily
think it has to be one of the other
yeah now me you know not being religious
um
i mean obviously i don't feel that
conflict right
but but our world views in general like
the we come across contradictions
between what we're observing and what
how we think the world should work a lot
and uh you know sometimes that's because
our world view is wrong
and so we can just give up on that other
times it's because
yeah like you said we're you're
misinterpreting something and i think
as humans we're almost too too excited
to think that everything needs to be uh
needs to work start to finish
that that we have to understand every
contradiction and every question before
we can
be comfortable in our own skin and i
think i think that if you go through
life that way
it doesn't matter if you're religious or
not like you're going to have trouble
being comfortable
because there's lots of lots of ideas
lots of things that we see
that conflict with other ideas and we
just can't uh we don't know why that is
one of the one of the examples that i
give on this is
you know if you think that gravity
should make all objects fall to the
ground
and then you see a bird fly you could
have a
um a crisis and and oh my gosh this
bird's violating the gravity uh
but if you understand that well
the bird is flying by pushing on air and
there's air pressure and
you know this all works actually because
of gravity pulling these air molecules
towards the earth and then
so you just see that there's there's
more to the explanation
and uh so i i would encourage
people not to require that everything
makes sense
in their own world view before they you
know can go and be active
in the world like we we can live with a
certain degree of contradiction and
that's okay
it's okay to say i don't know right you
know i say i don't know all the time
right right um yeah
so well jay any any last words of wisdom
before we we end things here
can't think of anything thanks so much
for having me john i really enjoyed it
yeah this is really cool i think
i think i'm trying to get some more
people from the center on nick nick's
expressed interest and a couple other
people are interested in coming on i
think
this could be a really cool series of uh
you know interviews with people at the
at the center so yeah and just the
caveat what
these are my opinions right these are
not the opinions of my employers or my
funding agencies
these are my opinions so yeah yeah and
and tell us again the name of the
organization that you work with you work
with seminaries
that are branching science for
seminaries it's a program
through uh the triple a s dialogue on
science
and religion are you a volunteer there
or they actually have grant money to
help you
so they're they're supported by a grant
so i'm like a science advisor for them
so i don't they have people that run
that program full time
yeah um i just like help out with things
here and there
oh cool well yeah that's that's it's
really awesome that you're doing that
it's it really is a
we live in an era of cultural culture
wars that are
getting out of hand lately so it's
really cool that
you're you're doing that outreach stuff
so yeah i really appreciate it
well thank you once again and stay
curious
everyone uh if you enjoyed this video
make sure to like it
and share it on social media and
i will see you next week next week is
actually going to be bert
hubert he's going to be talking about
the cell from a programming perspective
he's a he
he's he's done by uh research and
biology but he actually started out his
career
working in computer science and he has
some really cool
there's some really cool parallels that
he likes to point out there
and it's we actually pre-recorded that
because
schedule conflicts but i will be in the
live comments responding to people's
questions there
next sunday that's 11 a.m as usual for
sunday morning science
and that's going to be really really fun
conversation so hopefully i'll see you
all there
until next time stay curious